From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. A few years back here in Chicago, we had some unusual weather and 18 people were struck by lightning in one month. 17 of them survived, and I set out to interview as many of them as would talk to me. The ones with the worst injuries remembered nothing of what happened to them. But the rest all described the moment they were hit in very similar terms. Mike Bergeron and Larry Wilson were on the golf course under an umbrella with two other guys when the lightning struck.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。几年前在芝加哥，我们经历了一些异常天气，一个月内有18人被闪电击中。其中17人幸存了下来，我决定采访尽可能多愿意跟我交谈的人。那些受伤最严重的人对发生的事情毫无记忆，但其他人描述被击中那一刻的用词非常相似。迈克·伯格伦和拉里·威尔逊当时正在高尔夫球场，和其他两个人一起躲在一把伞下，这时闪电击中了他们。
All I saw was just a very bright white flash.
我只看到了一道非常明亮的白光。
I think I remember a white light. And when the lightning struck, I felt no pain.
我记得有一道白光。闪电击中时，我没有感到任何疼痛。
And I can remember, or what I think I remember, is just getting knocked backward. My brain saying, hey, you've got to stand up, and nothing else would really respond.
我记得的，或者说我认为我记得的，就是我向后跌倒了。我的大脑在说：“嘿，你得站起来。”但身体的其他部位完全没有反应。
And I was trying to call friends over. I remember that. But I couldn't speak.
我当时试着呼唤朋友过来。我记得那个。但我说不出话。
And it was like things kind of went in slow motion. Out of the corner of my eye, I can remember seeing Tony falling backward. I can remember seeing Larry falling, but it wasn't like somebody just tripping and falling on the ground. It was like it took them one or two minutes before they actually hit the ground.
感觉就像一切都变成了慢动作。我用余光看到托尼向后倒去。我记得看到拉里倒下，但那不像有人被绊倒摔在地上。感觉就像过了两三分钟他们才真正触地。
There's a terror to lightning. Victims say they were surrounded by friends and family. But when the bolt came, they were suddenly alone, trapped in their own bodies. The natural world turned supernatural. Georgiana Davies was at a company picnic when it just started to drizzle. She never saw the blast. She didn't suspect lightning. She says she thought it was the end of the world.
闪电有一种令人恐惧的力量。受害者说他们当时被朋友和家人包围，但当闪电袭来时，他们突然变得孤身一人，被困在自己的身体里。自然世界变得超自然了。乔治亚娜·戴维斯当时在参加公司野餐，天刚开始下小雨。她根本没看到闪光，也没怀疑是闪电。她说她当时以为那是世界末日。
Right before all this happened, it was like everybody just shut the sound completely out. You couldn't hear nothing. You couldn't move. It was like total silence around the world in that area where I was at. And then I started hearing humming, like bees or something, or a bunch of flies going zz-zz-zz.
在这件事发生前，感觉就像周围所有的声音都被彻底切断了。你听不到任何声音。你无法动弹。我所在的那个区域周围就像世界彻底静止了一样。然后我开始听到嗡嗡声，像蜜蜂或者是成群的苍蝇在响，滋——滋——滋。
And it felt like something was going to happen, but I didn't know what. And then I looked over and I saw Sylvia screaming. And I saw her mouth open but I couldn't hear her at first. It was like everything was shut out for-- I don't know if it was seconds or minutes. Or it could have been a second. And I didn't know where I was at.
感觉好像要发生什么事，但我不知道是什么。然后我抬头看，看到西尔维亚在尖叫。我看到她张着嘴，但起初我听不到她的声音。感觉一切都被切断了——我不知道是几秒钟还是几分钟，也可能只有一秒。我当时不知道自己身在何处。
That's what it was like in the moment lightning struck. But in the moments after, the days and weeks after, it all started to look different. When something happens to you that is so big, so biblical, you definitely start to think about why. And most of the survivors I talked to came to the same conclusion. It was not just a coincidence, where the lightning hit.
闪电击中那一刻就是这样。但在那之后的片刻、几天和几周里，一切开始看起来不同了。当一件如此重大、如此符合圣经描述的事情发生在你身上时，你一定会开始思考原因。我采访的大多数幸存者都得出了同样的结论：闪电击中的位置绝非巧合。
My own opinion, I think God's trying to tell the world something.
我个人的观点是，我认为上帝想要告诉世人一些事情。
They say God is trying to tell us something. Well, God don't try. God is telling us something. God don't try to do nothing. He's telling us something. Beware. He's coming back, and beware and be ready.
他们说上帝想要告诉我们一些事。嗯，上帝从不“想要”做什么。上帝就是在告诉我们一些事。上帝不会试图去做任何事。他在告诉我们一些事。警惕吧。他要回来了，要警惕，并做好准备。
My belief is there's a purpose to whatever happens. There's reasons behind it.
我的信念是，无论发生什么都有其目的。背后都有原因。
Well, today on our program, we try a little experiment. Usually we bring you stories of people in the middle of big experiences, whose lives are going through some sort of change, some growth, or some crisis. But sometimes, that moment of dramatic change is only half the story. The other half happens after time passes and they return to revisit that moment. Today's program is about what they find later and what remains of who and what they once were.
今天我们的节目里，我们尝试一个小实验。通常我们会为您讲述人们经历重大事件、生活经历某种变化、成长或危机的故事。但有时，那种戏剧性变化的时刻只是故事的一半。另一半发生在时光流逝，他们回头重温那一刻之后。今天的节目就是关于他们后来发现了什么，以及他们曾经的身份和拥有的一切还剩下什么。
Our show today in three acts. Act One, I Used to Bank Here But That Was Long, Long Ago, in which David Rakoff returns to the city he grew up to find buried, frozen treasure. Act Two, Exiles on Main Street. A young Russian emigre returns to the heroes of his youth, the brave Soviet dissidents who risked their lives at the height of the Cold War who were forced out of the Soviet Union. What have they been doing all these decades, the many dissidents who resettled in comfortable houses, not just in America, but in the American suburbs? Act Three, Shopping for a Better Tomorrow, the story of a social experiment involving a supermarket and 6,000 poor people. Stay with us.
今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕：《我过去常在那儿存钱，但那是很久很久以前的事了》，大卫·拉科夫回到他长大的城市，寻找埋藏的、冰封的宝藏。第二幕：《大街上的流亡者》。一位年轻的俄罗斯移民回到他青春时代的英雄们身边——那些在冷战高峰期冒着生命危险，被迫离开苏联的勇敢的苏联异见人士身边。几十年来，那些定居在舒适房子里的异见人士，不仅是在美国，而且是在美国郊区的异见人士都在做什么？第三幕：《为更美好的明天购物》，一个涉及一家超市和6000名贫困人口的社会实验故事。请继续收听。
Act One, I Used to Bank Here But That Was Long, Long Ago. David Rakoff recently flew to Toronto, where he grew up, to revisit a time in his life that for years he joked about, he downplayed, and he tried not to think about. He tells the story of what he found.
第一幕：《我过去常在那儿存钱，但那是很久很久以前的事了》。大卫·拉科夫最近飞回了他成长的多伦多，重温他生命中一段多年来他一直开玩笑、轻描淡写并尽量不去想的时光。他讲述了他所发现的故事。
At age 22, I had Hodgkin's disease. It is a form of lymphatic cancer common among young men in their 20s. It is also highly curable, so highly curable, in fact, that I like to refer to it as "the dilettante cancer."
22岁那年，我患了霍奇金淋巴瘤。这是年轻男性中常见的一种淋巴癌。而且它极易治愈，事实上由于它太容易治愈了，我喜欢称它为“业余爱好癌症”。
An old Canadian joke bears telling here. A boss says to an underling, "I'm off to Sault Ste. Marie for the weekend."
这里有个古老的加拿大笑话值得一讲。老板对下属说：“这个周末我要去苏圣玛丽。”
"Sault Ste. Marie," asks the employee, incredulous. "But boss, there are only whores and hockey players in Sault Ste. Marie."
“苏圣玛丽？”员工难以置信地问，“可是老板，苏圣玛丽除了妓女就是曲棍球手。”
"My wife is from Sault Ste. Marie."
“我太太就是苏圣玛丽人。”
"Oh," says the employee. "What position does she play?"
“噢，”员工说，“那她打什么位置？”
When I joke about Hodgkin's being the cancer for boys who do things in half measures, it is invariably to someone whose husband or brother or son has just died from Hodgkin's. I don't mean to denigrate other survivors or less fortunate non-survivors. My inappropriate wisecrack only serves to prove a point about myself.
当我开玩笑说霍奇金淋巴瘤是那种做事半途而废的男孩才会得的癌症时，我总是对着那些丈夫、兄弟或儿子刚刚死于霍奇金淋巴瘤的人说。我无意诋毁其他幸存者或那些不幸离世的人。我这种不合时宜的俏皮话只是为了证明关于我自己的一个观点。
On some level, despite the fact that I received both radiation and chemotherapy, I cannot escape the feeling that I was at best a cancer tourist, that my survival means I dabbled. Kind of been there, sort of done that. It has only recently occurred to me that perhaps I might stop glibly insisting that the cancer wasn't real and that the doctors popped me into an Easy-Bake Oven where a 40-watt light bulb halted the metastasis in its tracks.
在某种程度上，尽管我同时接受了放疗和化疗，但我无法摆脱一种感觉，即我充其量是个“癌症游客”，我的幸存意味着我只是浅尝辄止。算是经历过，算是做过吧。直到最近我才意识到，也许我应该停止轻率地坚持说那次癌症不是真的，坚持说医生把我塞进了一个简易烤箱里，那里面的40瓦灯泡就把我的癌细胞转移给中止了。
What remains some 13 years after the fact? Four small tattoos, subcutaneous black dots like compass points on my torso, near-total numbness in the very tips of my fingers, as well as a palm-sized area on my right inner thigh, also without feeling, some dry mouth, and most lastingly, three straws of my pre-chemotherapized sperm in cold storage somewhere in Toronto. Like millions of tiny Walt Disneys, they wait, frozen, until the day when I will return and have them conjoined with some willing ovum and thereby fulfill their zygotic destiny, growing into children who will eventually go on to break my heart and not talk to me.
13年后还剩下什么？我的躯干上有四个小纹身，像指南针点一样的皮下黑点；我的手指尖几乎完全麻木，右大腿内侧还有一块手掌大小的区域也失去了知觉；有些口干；最持久的是，我预存的三管精子在多伦多的某个地方冷冻着。就像数百万个微小的华特·迪士尼，它们冷冻在那里，等待着有一天我回来，让它们与某个愿意的卵子结合，从而实现它们的受精使命，成长为最终会伤透我的心、不再与我交谈的孩子。
More than a desire for kids who can be fairly boring, truth be told, I just want to know where the sperm is. Easier said than done, as it turns out, because since that time, I have moved, my parents have moved, the sperm bank has moved, and the cancer hospital has moved. The traces have been thoroughly kicked over, which suits me fine. I'm not by nature terribly sentimental. I'm not a photo taker. I have no scrapbooks. I have attempted to never look back-- until now.
说实话，比起想要孩子（那可能挺无聊的），我只是想知道精子在哪里。事实证明，这说起来容易做起来难，因为从那时起，我搬过家，我父母搬过家，精子银行搬过家，癌症医院也搬过家。线索已经被彻底抹去了，这正合我意。我天生不是一个特别多愁善感的人。我不爱拍照。我没有剪贴簿。我一直试图不回头看——直到现在。
Along with my scar, my tattoos, and my numbness, these straws of sperm are the only things I have left from that time in my life, a period of 18 months that I have generally tried to not think about. 13 years later, at the age of 35, it's starting to seem like bad juju to continue to ignore it. And so I am off to find the straws, just in time for their putative, microscopic Bar Mitzvahs.
除了伤疤、纹身和麻木，这些精子是我生命中那段时期唯一剩下的东西。那段18个月的经历，我通常都尽量不去想。13年后，35岁的我开始觉得继续忽视它有些不祥。所以我要去寻找这些精子，正好赶上它们理论上的、微观的受戒仪式。
I was treated at PMH, the Princess Margaret Hospital, the main cancer facility in Toronto. If you were a child at any time from the 1930s through the 1950s living anywhere in the British empire, chances are you were inundated with images of the two young princesses, Elizabeth and Margaret. Elizabeth would eventually become Queen, of course, but Margaret was always considered to be somewhat prettier. And simply by virtue of her thwarted ascendancy to the throne, she was less duty bound, and consequently more fun, kinky almost.
我是在玛格丽特公主医院（PMH）接受治疗的，那是多伦多主要的癌症中心。如果你在1930年代到1950年代期间是生活在英帝国任何地方的孩子，你很可能被两位年轻公主——伊丽莎白和玛格丽特的影像所包围。伊丽莎白最终成了女王，那是理所当然的，但玛格丽特一直被认为稍微漂亮一点。仅仅因为她错过了王位继承权，她受到的责任束缚较少，因此更风趣，甚至有点时髦。
As she grew up and had her serial doomed romances, Margaret gave the commonwealth public a taste of the kind of low-rent scandal we could later come to expect from the House of Windsor. It's not like she was a slattern or an embarrassment. Calling it the Princess Margaret Hospital is not like naming it the Billy Carter. It's more affectionate than that, more glamorous. The Tricia Nixon might be more apt.
随着她长大并经历一系列注定的不幸恋情，玛格丽特让英联邦公众尝到了我们后来在温莎家族中预期会看到的那种低级丑闻。并不是说她是个荡妇或丢人现眼。把它命名为“玛格丽特公主医院”并不像命名为“比利·卡特医院”那样。它更亲切，更有魅力。叫“特里西娅·尼克松医院”可能更贴切。
Hanging on the wall on the way to the radiation room in the old hospital was a photograph of Princess Margaret's hand, taken on the occasion of the inauguration of the building. It was actually an x-ray photograph, so her highness's jewelry glows white against the bones in the vaporous gray of her invisible flesh. I look at it every time I go for treatment.
旧医院通往放疗室的墙上挂着一张玛格丽特公主手的照片，那是该建筑落成时拍摄的。那实际上是一张X光片，所以殿下的珠宝在骨骼上闪着白光，映衬着她那隐形血肉虚无缥缈的灰色。每次去治疗，我都会看着它。
The radiation room itself is a lead-lined interior chamber of the hospital. Two red laser beams cross over the exact center of the table where the patients lie. Using the cross of four small black tattoos on my torso, the technicians line me up and ready me for the thousands of rads of radiation. The machine is bulbous, huge, and a dull hospital-green, a death ray straight out of '50s sci-fi.
放疗室本身是医院里的一间铅衬内室。两束红色激光交叉在病人躺着的台子正中央。利用我躯干上四个小黑纹身的十字标记，技师们把我对准位置，为我准备接受数千雷德的辐射。那台机器球状、巨大，呈呆滞的医院绿色，就像50年代科幻片里的死亡射线。
I lie down and look up. Above my head, directly at eye level, someone has drawn a hastily-rendered happy face in magic marker. Underneath that is written the message, "give us a smile." Like Rita Hayworth's picture that graced the side of the atom bomb they dropped on Bikini Atoll, there's something so pathetic, so vastly outmatched about this little happy face. It is like putting a garnish on annihilation. Still, I never fail to smile. Even when I reach the point in the treatments when most of my hair has fallen out and my throat has been burned to such an extent that I cannot swallow, I smile.
我躺下向上看。在我头顶上方，视线平齐的位置，有人用马克笔匆忙画了一个笑脸。下面写着“给我们一个微笑”。就像当年扔在比基尼环礁的原子弹侧面贴着的丽塔·海华丝照片一样，这个小小的笑脸显得如此可悲，如此无力。这就像是在毁灭之物上摆放一道配菜。不过，我每次都不禁会笑。即使当我治疗到头发掉光、喉咙灼伤到无法吞咽时，我也会笑。
[MUSIC - "CAN'T TAKE MY EYES OFF YOU" BY FRANKIE VALLI]
[音乐 - 弗兰基·瓦利的《Can't Take My Eyes Off You》]
They haven't stopped at the happy face, either. Every time the lead door closes, latching with a booming clank, so, too, begins the music, the same song every time, the same place in the same song every time. The full horn section buildup of the chorus to the song-- "you're just too good to be true." The plutonium drops down into the central cone, a warm wind starts to blow on my chest, indicating that I'm now getting the equivalent of a lifetime's worth of the recommended dose of gamma radiation, and I smile.
他们不止用了那个笑脸。每次铅门关闭，发出轰鸣的金属碰撞声时，音乐就会响起，每次都是同一首歌，每次都是那首歌的同一个位置。合唱部分的管乐全奏响起——“你真是好得让人难以置信”。钚掉进中央锥体，一阵暖风开始吹向我的胸口，表明我正在接受相当于一辈子推荐剂量的伽马射线辐射，我笑了。
The harvesting of sperm before chemotherapy is a fairly standard practice. Chemo makes you sterile. They suggest it to most male patients of a certain age. It is certainly the most important sperm sample I've ever given, but it is not the first. In 1982 as a freshman, I sold it once. Every bulletin board in my dormitory on 114th Street and Amsterdam Avenue had the following flyer-- "College men, make money now." It was an advertisement for a midtown sperm bank. We would be paid close to $50 to do, under somewhat more controlled circumstances, the very thing that was occupying a great deal of our waking lives anyway.
化疗前采集精子是相当标准的操作。化疗会让你不孕。他们建议大多数达到一定年龄的男性患者这样做。这无疑是我提供过的最重要的精子样本，但不是第一个。1982年我大一时，曾卖过一次。我宿舍所在的第114街和阿姆斯特丹大道的每一个公告栏上都贴着这张传单——“大学生，现在就赚钱”。那是一家中城精子银行的广告。只要做那件我们清醒时大部分时间都在做的事情，在更有控制的环境下，我们就能获得近50美元的报酬。
The lab was very interested in our seed, the sperm of the Ivy League. There's something so obscenely vital, so borderline eugenic about that image, imbued with a potency and a Riefenstahlian vision of the future. It was a stereotype much greater than the actual sum of its parts, I can assure you, given some of the knock-kneed Hebrews I went to school with, myself included.
实验室对我们的种子很感兴趣，也就是常春藤盟校的精子。那个形象带有一种如此猥琐的活力，如此接近优生学，充满了潜能和里芬斯塔尔式的未来愿景。我可以向你保证，这比其实际价值的综合要夸张得多，考虑到我和我的一些罗圈腿希伯来同学，包括我自己在内。
I remember nothing from that day. I cannot tell you if there were dirty magazines, although I suspect there were. I cannot remember being embarrassed, although I'm sure I was. And I cannot remember what I was paid, although $40 cash rings a bell. The conflation of climax in commerce cannot have failed to escape my notice. At age 17, it felt like sexual transgression. I suppose it still does, since until this moment, I have never told anyone about it.
我不记得那天发生的一切。我无法告诉你是否有色情杂志，虽然我怀疑有。我不记得感到尴尬，虽然我肯定很尴尬。我不记得我得到了多少报酬，虽然40美元现金听起来很耳熟。当时我不可能没注意到高潮与商业的结合。17岁那年，这感觉像是一种性越轨。我想现在依然如此，因为直到这一刻，我从未告诉过任何人。
It is now a gray Toronto day in January of the new century. The new Princess Margaret facility is beautiful, occupying an old art deco insurance building. It is imposing and gray and elegant and graced in the center with a soaring, six-story atrium. It is nothing like the old hospital where I was treated. I feel a little jealous as I walk in. There's even a multi-faith chapel which I don't recall from the old place.
现在是新世纪一月一个阴沉的多伦多日子。玛格丽特公主医院的新设施很漂亮，坐落在一栋装饰艺术风格的旧保险大楼里。它宏伟、灰暗、优雅，中央有一个高耸的六层中庭。它和我接受治疗时的老医院完全不同。走进去时我感到有点嫉妒。甚至还有一个我不记得老地方有的多信仰礼拜堂。
Outside of it, on a white board, someone on staff has written, "just a thought," and then a quote-- "joy is not in things, it is in us." It is attributed to one Robert Wagner, whose dates are 1813 to 1883. Presumably this is a different Robert Wagner than the wattle-concealing, turtleneck-wearing star of The Towering Inferno and Heart To Heart. So different a Robert Wagner, in fact, that when I tried to look him up in my Bartlett's Quotations, he is not listed.
在它外面的一块白板上，员工写着“一点感想”，接着是一句引语——“快乐不在事物中，而在我们心中。”这被归于某个罗伯特·瓦格纳，其生卒年为1813年至1883年。想必这和那位出演《火烧摩天楼》和《用心》、遮着赘肉戴着高领毛衣的明星罗伯特·瓦格纳不是同一个人。事实上，这个罗伯特·瓦格纳太不同了，以至于当我试图在我的《巴特莱引语集》中查找他时，上面并没有列出。
Who is listed there, with exactly the same dates, however, is Richard Wagner, he of the proto-Nazi operas of heroic Ubermenschen. Funnily enough, Bartlett's doesn't list this lovely caveat against materialism among the composer's notable quotes. But it's a lot more suitable for an oncology chapel after all than "To be German means to carry on a matter for its own sake," don't you think?
不过，上面列出的、生卒年完全相同的是理查德·瓦格纳，那位创作了英雄超人纳粹式歌剧的作曲家。有趣的是，《巴特莱集》并没有把这句反对物质主义的美好忠告列入该作曲家的著名引语中。但毕竟，它比起“成为德国人意味着为了事物本身而从事它”更适合肿瘤科礼拜堂，你不觉得吗？
This new place is completely devoid of anything I might recall. Not a single doctor who treated me still works here. The fondly remembered x-ray photograph of Princess Margaret's hand is also nowhere to be seen. I ask the volunteer at the desk if they brought it here from the old facility. "It was on the way to radiation," I say.
这个新地方完全没有我可能记忆中的任何东西。曾经治疗过我的医生现在一个都不在这里工作了。那张令人怀念的玛格丽特公主手的X光片也不知所踪。我问前台的志愿者，他们是否把它从老设施带过来了。“它以前在通往放疗室的路上，”我说。
"I was also a radiation patient," she replies. "I don't remember it." I then ask her if she remembers the music during treatment. She doesn't dismiss my recollection, but she's not sure herself, it was so long ago. All memory is porous. Details can change or go missing entirely, particularly in moments of physical peril. A kind of amnesia goes hand in hand sickness, and a good thing, too. But of these two details-- that x-ray photograph, that music-- I am sure. I think.
“我也是放疗患者，”她回答说，“我不记得了。”我接着问她是否记得治疗期间的音乐。她没有否认我的回忆，但她自己也不确定，毕竟太久以前了。所有的记忆都是多孔的。细节可能会改变或完全缺失，尤其是在面临身体危险的时刻。一种失忆伴随着疾病而来，这其实也是件好事。但对于这两个细节——那张X光片，那段音乐——我很确定。我想。
It's not all that hard to locate the missing sperm lab. A few phone calls and I find that it has been moved lock, stock, and barrel to another more centrally-located hospital. When I finally call them up directly to see if they still have my straws, they know all too well who I am. They have been waiting for me, or more precisely, for my money.
定位缺失的精子实验室并不难。几个电话后，我就发现它被彻底搬到了另一家位于市中心的医院。当我最终直接打电话询问他们是否还有我的精子样本时，他们非常清楚我是谁。他们一直在等我，或者更确切地说，在等我的钱。
There are apparently years of storage fees outstanding. I owe close to $1,000. What would have happened if I had never checked up on this, I wonder? Would I one day be walking past some pawn shop in Toronto, and there in the window next to the watches, the saxophone, the old Canadian Legion of Honor war medallions are three straws of my semen falling out in a dusty shaft of sunlight?
据说有几年的储存费还没交。我欠了近1000美元。我心想，如果我从来没查过这件事会怎样？我会有一天走在多伦多某家典当行外，在橱窗里手表、萨克斯风、旧加拿大荣誉勋章旁边看到我三管冷冻在灰尘阳光里的精子吗？
The folks at the lab view me with suspicion, but not because I am a deadbeat dad. What the folks at the lab seem disquieted by is this radio story. They don't really understand why I want to tell it. I am reduced to using icky tricks, preambling each phone call by describing myself as having been "a cancer patient," which seems a little melodramatic to me and leaves them completely unmoved anyway.
实验室的人看我的眼神充满了怀疑，但这并不是因为我是个不负责任的父亲。真正让实验室的人感到不安的是这段广播故事。他们真的不明白我为什么要讲这个。我不得不使用一些卑劣的手段，在每个电话开头都先描述自己曾经是“一名癌症患者”，这对我来说显得有点矫情，而且他们对此也完全无动于衷。
Or if I'm not being treacly, I'm playing the ridiculous schlemiel, stammering and apologizing. It leaves me with a bad taste in my mouth, and all to no avail. What begins as frosty but cordial relations between the nursing manager and myself devolves steadily. I fly to Toronto and she refuses to speak with me outright. I am Scrooge, revisiting Christmas past, walking through a room, trying to right a wrong and being completely unheard and unable to physically manifest. I will not be able to see the facility, tour the vault or wherever it is they keep the straws, or ask her my many medical questions. My audience with the sperm of the Ivy League is denied.
如果我不表现得那么忧郁，我就在扮演那个可笑的倒霉蛋，结结巴巴地道歉。这让我嘴里留下一种苦味，而且毫无成效。我和护理经理之间原本寒暄但客气的关系不断恶化。我飞到多伦多，她拒绝直接跟我说话。我成了重温过去圣诞节的斯克鲁奇，走过一个房间，试图纠正一个错误，却完全被无视，无法产生任何现实影响。我将无法参观那个设施，参观他们存放精子的金库，或问她我那些众多的医疗问题。我与我那份常春藤盟校精子的会面被拒绝了。
I recall the last time I saw these fugitive children of mine. It was in the summer of 1987. By that time, my illness was fairly advanced. I was some 35 pounds underweight, an old man at the age of 23. Virtually the last thing on my mind was onanism. I had been told if I could get the sample downtown to the lab within 45 minutes, I could do the harvest at home. To this end, the lab technician at the sperm bank had given me some sterile containers.
我回想起最后一次见到我这些逃亡的孩子们。那是1987年的夏天。那时，我的病情已经相当严重。我体重偏轻约35磅，23岁就成了个老人。我脑子里几乎最后考虑的就是手淫。我被告知如果能在45分钟内把样本送到市中心的实验室，我可以在家里采集。为此，精子银行的实验员给了我几个无菌容器。
In the abstract, this sounded far more comfortable, producing my sample in the privacy of my childhood bedroom. But privacy isn't really the name of the game when your mother has to drive you to the hospital. I've never been licensed by a sitting government to drive a car, and I'm far too weak to take public transport. By happy coincidence, my mother's office is two blocks away from the hospital. After breakfast, she says to me euphemistically, "I'm going to start the car. Why don't you go upstairs and get ready," emphasis and winking italics my own. If this freaks her out, she doesn't let on. She's a physician herself, so it might just seem par for the course to tell your youngest child to go upstairs and salute the archbishop and then join you in the car.
抽象地看，这听起来舒服多了，在童年卧室的私密空间里采集我的样本。但当你要母亲开车送你去医院时，私密感就不存在了。我从未领过现任政府颁发的驾照，而且我太虚弱了，无法乘坐公共交通。巧合的是，我母亲的办公室离医院只有两个街区。早餐后，她委婉地对我说：“我去发动车子。你为什么不上去准备一下呢？”（这里的强调和斜体眨眼是我自己加的）。如果这让她感到震惊，她也没有表现出来。她自己就是一名内科医生，所以告诉她最小的孩子上去向大主教致敬然后再上车跟她会合，可能被视为正常流程。
My deed done-- not my finest effort after what has arguably been half a lifetime of practice-- I put on my coat and grab the jar. It is made of clear plastic. In college, my friend's parents came to New York for a psychoanalysts convention. Getting onto a hotel elevator crowded with their colleagues, my friend turned to his mother and stage whispered, "Jocasta, I want you." But it is just me and my mother in the car. There are no Freudians to entertain with the discomfort of the Oedipal situation.
我的任务完成后——在我大半辈子实践之后，这算不上我最好的努力——我穿上外套，抓起罐子。它是透明塑料做的。在大学里，我朋友的父母来纽约参加心理分析大会。进入挤满同事的酒店电梯时，我的朋友转向他母亲，舞台耳语道：“约卡斯塔，我要你。”但车里只有我和我母亲。没有弗洛伊德主义者能让我用俄狄浦斯情结的尴尬来取悦。
Even in my weakened state, I'm certainly not going to ride next to my mother with a transparent vial of spooge in my lap. I look around the kitchen for a suitable bag and find the perfect one. It is four by six of white paper. It has clearly been in the kitchen since I was very young, because when I turn it over, I see that it's printed with the image of an orange pumpkin and a black cat, and in dripping, blood-soaked calligraphy, the words "trick or treat."
即使在我虚弱的状态下，我也绝对不会带着一小瓶透明的精液坐在我母亲身边。我在厨房里找了一个合适的袋子，找到了最完美的一个。那是一个四乘六的白纸袋。它显然从我很小的时候就在厨房了，因为当我翻过来时，看到上面印着一只橘色南瓜和一只黑猫的图案，还有用滴着血的书法写着的字样：“不给糖就捣蛋”。
Among my destinations on this trip up to Toronto is the site of the old hospital. I'm told it's being used now as a homeless shelter. It was in one of Toronto's few rubby-dub neighborhoods. There were a lot of hookers and also a Christian ministry back when I was a patient. The area has clearly been cleaned up, because I don't see any hookers or visibly Christian folks either. And the purported homeless people going into the old Princess Margaret all look like backpacking Northern Europeans.
这次多伦多之行，我的目的地之一就是老医院的旧址。听说它现在被用作流浪者收容所。当年我住在那儿时，那里是多伦多为数不多的肮脏街区之一。有很多妓女，还有一个基督教事工。那个地区显然已经被清理过了，因为我既没看到妓女，也没看到明显的基督徒。走进老玛格丽特公主医院的那些所谓的流浪汉，看起来都像是背着背包的北欧人。
I stand in the circular driveway, the place where the smoking patients used to congregate with their IV stands and enjoy their last cigarettes. I think of that song "This Used to be My Playground." I'm trying to actually feel something about the whole thing as I stand there, but I'm not really coming up with anything. The building is possibly one of the more important structures in my life. I feel like I should well up with some sort of nostalgic yearning, mourning my youth, anything. But it's just not happening, which is very strange. Or not.
我站在环形车道上，那是过去吸烟的病人们推着静脉输液架聚集在一起享受最后一根香烟的地方。我想到那首《这曾是我的游乐场》。当我站在那儿时，我试图对这一切产生某种感受，但我真的什么也没想出来。那栋建筑可能是我生命中最重要的建筑之一。我觉得我应该涌起某种怀旧的渴望，哀悼我的青春，什么都行。但什么都没发生，这很奇怪。或者也不奇怪。
Once on my way home from radiation, a man came running out of the Knights of Columbus chapter near the hospital. Another man came running after him. And like a cartoon panel come to life, the man giving chase actually yelled, "Stop! Thief!" I remember thinking to myself, "well, that's very cliche." I was close to the robber. I could have stuck my foot out and tripped him perhaps, but I didn't. He made it across the street, dodging traffic, and was out of sight in a moment.
有一次我放疗回来的路上，一个男人从医院附近的哥伦布骑士会分会跑了出来。另一个人追在他后面。就像动画片成真了一样，那个追赶的人真的大喊：“站住！小偷！”我记得当时心想：“噢，那真是太老套了。”我就在那小偷旁边。也许我本可以伸出脚把他绊倒，但我没有。他穿过街道，躲避着交通，转眼间就消失不见了。
The man from the Knights of Columbus stood frustrated on the sidewalk as the cars rushed by. He turned and gave me a dirty look for my inaction. I wanted to say something. I wanted to explain how weak and tired and sick I was at that point, but more than that how I had essentially let go of any sense of agency. I could lie on a table. They could shoot me full of gamma rays. I would eat what was put in front of me. The hair could fall from my head. My throat could be burned. But I was not involved. I was a stranger here. That he could even see me standing there seemed vaguely surprising.
哥伦布骑士会的那个人在路边挫败地站着，看着汽车呼啸而过。他转过身，因为我的无所作为给了我一个恶狠狠的眼神。我想说点什么。我想解释我当时是多么虚弱、疲惫和生病，但更重要的是，我已经失去了任何自主意识。我可以躺在桌子上。他们可以向我射入伽马射线。我会吃摆在我面前的东西。我的头发可以从头上掉落。我的喉咙可以被灼伤。但我没有参与其中。我是这里的陌生人。他甚至能看到我站在那里，这看起来都隐约让人感到惊讶。
They say that times of crisis are the true test of one's character. I really wouldn't know, since my character took a powder that year, leaving in its stead a jewel-bright hardness. I was at my very cleverest that year, an airless, relentless kind of quippiness. Every time a complex human emotion threatened to break the surface of my consciousness, out would come a joke. Come on, give us a smile.
人们说危机时刻是检验一个人性格的真正时刻。我真的不知道，因为那一年的我性格已经“辞职”了，取而代之的是一种宝石般明亮而坚硬的东西。那一年我最聪明，是一种无空气的、无情的俏皮劲儿。每当一种复杂的复杂人类情感试图冲破我的意识表面，我就会讲个笑话。来吧，给我们一个微笑。
I was Thanatos' rodeo clown. I still am. And Eros' as well, as it turns out. Years later, in a tender embrace in bed with my first real boyfriend, he said my name. "Oh, David." I stopped, sat up, and responded in my best Ed Wynn, "mm-yesss?" This kind of behavior essentially killed things between us.
我是塔纳托斯的牛仔小丑。我现在依然是。事实证明，也是厄洛斯的。多年后，在床上与我第一个真正的男朋友温柔拥抱时，他叫了我的名字。“噢，大卫。”我停了下来，坐起来，用我最好的艾德·温声音回应道：“嗯——是的？”这种行为基本上扼杀了我们之间的关系。
There was a period during the illness when I was at my very sickest, at 115 pounds hovering in and out of consciousness. This month and a half was the one period in my life when I was not faking it, where I was not deflecting every emotion with repartee. That it would take millions of cancer cells lining up for their big Esther Williams finale in my lymphatic system for me to finally shut up is sobering. Or would be, were I to think about, which of course I choose not to.
在患病期间有一段时期我病得最重，体重115磅，徘徊在意识昏迷的边缘。这一个半月是我生命中唯一一段我不假装、不试图用机智来抵消所有情感的时期。为了让我终于闭嘴，竟然需要数百万个癌细胞在我的淋巴系统中排成一排准备它们的盛大谢幕，这真是令人清醒。如果我愿意去思考的话，但当然，我选择不去思考。
What remains of your past if you didn't allow yourself to feel it when it happened? If you don't have your experiences in the moment, if you gloss them over with jokes or zoom past them, you end up with curiously dispassionate memories, procedural and de-populated. It's as if a neutron bomb went off and all you're left with are hospital corridors where you're scanning the walls for familiar photographs. Sometimes in the absence of emotion, your only recourse is to surround yourself with objects, assemble the relics about you, as I am doing in flying to Toronto to commune with my little Eskimo Pie children. For the moment, this physical evidence will have to serve as proof that the illness was real, because even now, I only half-believe what I'm telling you.
如果你在过去发生时不允许自己去感受它，那还剩下什么？如果你不在那一刻去体验，如果你用笑话掩盖它们或闪电般跳过它们，你最终只会得到奇怪的、冷漠的记忆，程序化且空无一物。就好像一颗中子弹爆炸了，你剩下的只有医院的走廊，你在走廊里扫视着墙壁寻找熟悉的照片。有时在缺乏情感的情况下，你唯一的求助方式就是用物品包围自己，收集那些遗迹，就像我飞往多伦多与我的“爱斯基摩派”孩子们交流所做的那样。目前，这些实物证据将不得不作为那场疾病是真实的证据，因为即使是现在，我也只相信你所听到的这一半。
David Rakoff in New York. Coming up, little pinko houses for you and me. Soviets move into Capitalist neighborhoods in America. And more in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
纽约的大卫·拉科夫。接下来，为你我准备的小粉红房子。苏联人搬进美国的资本主义社区。Public Radio International 的节目将在片刻后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, What Remains, stories in which people return to a scene of big, dramatic change years after the fact. We have arrived at act two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，《依然留存》，讲述了人们在多年后重返发生巨大戏剧性变化的现场的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Exiles on Main Street. What remains of the Cold War now, years later? Keith Gessen's family were Soviet Jews, who emigrated from Moscow in 1981 when Keith was six. They eventually moved to the well-off suburb of Newton, Massachusetts, where Keith learned to revere certain heroes of the Cold War, heroes who included people just down the street.
第二幕：《大街上的流亡者》。多年后，冷战还剩下什么？基思·格森的家庭是苏联犹太人，1981年基思六岁时从莫斯科移民。他们最终搬到了马萨诸塞州富裕的郊区牛顿市，在那里基思学会了崇敬冷战的某些英雄，包括就住在街头的英雄们。
Our house in Newton looked like all the other houses, which in turn looked like ours. But in fact, our home was an enclave of Moscow culture. Our best loved writers were those who had stood up to Stalin and died for it. The only framed photo in the entire house was of me at 12 with a kindly old man who everyone assumed was my grandfather, but who was, in fact, Andrei Sakharov, the inventor of the Soviet hydrogen bomb who later became a dissident and winner of the Nobel Peace Prize.
我们在牛顿的房子看起来和其他房子一模一样，而那些房子也看起来和我们的一样。但实际上，我们的家是一个莫斯科文化的飞地。我们最喜爱的作家是那些对抗斯大林并为此献身的人。家里唯一装裱的照片是我12岁时和一个慈祥的老人的合影，大家都以为那是我的祖父，但实际上他是安德烈·萨哈罗夫，苏联氢弹的发明者，后来成为异见人士并获得了诺贝尔和平奖。
And then there was the soundtrack to my childhood. I put in my hours of rap music and The Doors. But when my parents controlled the tape deck, we listened to Alexander Galich, a Soviet dissident who sang with great pathos of labor camps, executioners, and exiles.
还有我童年的配乐。我听过我的饶舌音乐和“大门”乐队。但当父母控制磁带时，我们听亚历山大·加利奇的歌，一位苏联异见人士，他以极大的悲悯演唱劳改营、刽子手和流亡者的故事。
[MUSIC BY ALEXANDER GALICH]
[亚历山大·加利奇的音乐]
These words were playing in cars and homes all across the suburbs of the Northeast states, where the Soviet dissidents landed in the '70s. Even now, after the Soviet Union has collapsed and they could go home, many of the most prominent former dissidents live in places like Revere, Massachusetts, Aberdeen, New Jersey, and Ithaca, New York. It never made sense to me. A whole heroic generation of Russians had gone from a place of drama and conviction to these dull, groomed streets. And I decided at long last to figure out why.
这些歌词曾在70年代苏联异见人士登陆的东北部各州郊区的汽车和家庭中播放。即使在今天，苏联解体了，他们可以回国了，许多最著名的前异见人士仍住在马萨诸塞州的里维尔、新泽西州的阿伯丁和纽约州的伊萨卡等地。这对我来说一直没道理。整整一代英雄般的俄罗斯人竟然从一个充满戏剧和信念的地方搬到了这些枯燥、整洁的街道。我最终决定弄清楚原因。
My name is Pavel Litvinov. I'm a physics teacher in Hackley School. And we are standing in my lab. It's a physics lab. That's where I teach and spend several hours every day, five days a week.
我叫帕维尔·利特维诺夫。我是哈克利学校的物理老师。我们现在正站在我的实验室里。这是一个物理实验室。这就是我教书、每天花几小时、每周五天呆的地方。
The Hackley School is a prep school on a pretty, hillside campus in Tarrytown, New York. But Litvinov's story of being a humdrum physics teacher won't fly with me. I know who he is.
哈克利学校是纽约州塔里镇一个漂亮山坡校园上的预科学校。但利特维诺夫关于自己是个乏味物理老师的故事说服不了我。我知道他是谁。
Well, we see our football field, but they actually play lacrosse because it's lacrosse season.
嗯，我们能看到橄榄球场，但他们实际上在打长曲棍球，因为现在是长曲棍球赛季。
This is the Litvinov who, when Soviet tanks entered Czechoslovakia in August, 1968, led the most famous Soviet protest of the Cold War era, a protest of eight people in Red Square who were quickly beaten up, arrested, and packed off to Siberia, labor camps, and a psychiatric institution. A few nights before going out into Red Square, Litvinov attended a get together where Alexander Galich himself, the singer so popular in my family's Cutlass Sierra, performed a new song about resisting authority, whose most ringing phrase was a call to arms. "Will you dare go out into the square at the appointed hour?" Well, Litvinov dared. He spent four years in Siberia and was forced out of the Soviet Union in 1974.
这就是那位利特维诺夫——当苏联坦克在1968年8月进入捷克斯洛伐克时，他领导了冷战时期最著名的苏联抗议活动，在那场红场上的八人抗议中，他们迅速被殴打、逮捕，并被遣送到西伯利亚、劳改营和精神病院。在去红场的前几个晚上，利特维诺夫参加了一个聚会，我家车里那盘磁带里的歌星亚历山大·加利奇本人也在场，演唱了一首关于抵抗权威的新歌，其最响亮的短语是战斗号角：“在约定的时刻，你敢走到广场上去吗？”嗯，利特维诺夫敢。他在西伯利亚待了四年，并于1974年被迫离开苏联。
For many people, it's just very strange that I was ready to risk my freedom and maybe even life. It's definitely different. And they look at me, a middle-aged man and so on. And I don't look like the one who would do such things. And they would be very much amazed.
对许多人来说，我准备好拿我的自由甚至生命去冒险，这非常奇怪。这绝对不同。他们看着我，一个中年男人等等。我不像是那种会做这种事的人。他们会感到非常惊讶。
It's not as if Litvinov stopped his political activity when he arrived in the states. Until the Soviet Union collapsed, he gave speeches, published a chronicle of Soviet human rights abuses, and served on the board of Amnesty International. But in America, politics were merely politics, not a way of being.
这并不是说利特维诺夫一到美国就停止了他的政治活动。在苏联解体前，他发表演讲，出版了苏联侵犯人权记录，并在国际特赦组织的董事会任职。但在美国，政治只是政治，不是一种生存方式。
Galich himself came to United States after immigration years ago after that. And we had a concert for him. A small concert, maybe about 40 people in some place across the river in Nyack. And he started to sing his songs. And in America, it didn't make much sense. It still was great poetry, great songs. But somehow, it didn't sound, and even Galich didn't sound the same. I remember listening to him in Moscow apartments when he was singing for dissidents, when the feeling of danger, feeling that tomorrow somebody can be arrested, some people were in prison, some people in labor camp, in mental hospital for their dissident activity. Everything was so sharp and so painful that Galich's songs were just a very subtle, very desperate thing.
加利奇本人几年前在移民后也来到了美国。我们为他举办了一场音乐会。一场小型的音乐会，可能大约40人在纽约州尼亚克的河对岸某个地方。他开始唱他的歌。在美国，这没什么意义。那仍然是伟大的诗歌，伟大的歌曲。但不知为何，听起来不太对劲，甚至加利奇本人听起来也不一样了。我记得在莫斯科公寓里听他为异见人士唱歌，当时那种危险感，那种明天可能有人会被捕的感觉，有些人进了监狱，有些人进了劳改营，有些人因为异见活动被关进精神病院。一切是如此尖锐和痛苦，以至于加利奇的歌曲只是一种非常微妙、非常绝望的东西。
He tells me that he doesn't regret coming here, that the achievements he's proud of these days are his successes with his students. Litvinov see nothing incongruous about Soviet dissidents settling in the American suburbs.
他告诉我他不后悔来这里，他如今引以为豪的成就是他在学生身上取得的成功。利特维诺夫认为苏联异见人士定居美国郊区一点也不矛盾。
That's what is great about America, because everyone in America is something, has some experience. You go and you find out that on the next street, there could be mobsters, there could be Soviet dissidents, there could be some character or some guy who made $20 million because he invented some software. And that's what is incredible in the United States.
这就是美国伟大之处，因为在美国每个人都是某个人，都有某种经历。你去寻找，会发现就在下一条街上，可能有黑帮分子，可能有苏联异见人士，可能有某个角色，或者某个因为发明了软件而赚了2000万美元的家伙。这就是美国令人难以置信的地方。
And yet his old friends in Russia are still on the front lines. Sergei Kovalev was Yeltsin's human rights commissioner and a longtime deputy in the Duma. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] is an important human rights activist.
然而他在俄罗斯的老朋友们仍在前线。谢尔盖·科瓦列夫是叶利钦的人权专员，也是杜马的资深代表。谢尔盖·格里戈良茨是一位重要的人权活动家。
And I cannot rid myself of the notion that there is another life that Litvinov might have lived, a heroic life in which he stayed in Russia. I ask him about it, about whether he ever thinks about that life. And finally, he tells me that of course he's thought about it. It would have meant going to a labor camp instead of coming here. And if he had come out alive, he tells me, well, then yes, he likely would have become a politician or activist after the regime collapsed.
我无法摆脱一种想法，即利特维诺夫本可以过另一种生活——一种留在俄罗斯的英雄生活。我问他这件事，问他是否曾想过那种生活。最后，他告诉我，他当然想过。这意味着去劳改营，而不是来到这里。如果他能活着出来，他告诉我，那是的， regime 垮台后他很可能会成为一名政治家或活动家。
He's very polite as he says this. If he had survived. Because millions died in those camps. And it dawns on me, more powerfully than it ever has, that in asking him if he feels out of place here, I'm asking if he might not rather be dead. By the time the Soviet Union did collapse and there was nothing preventing him from moving back, he felt it was too late.
他说这话时非常有礼貌。如果他活下来的话。因为数以百万计的人死在了那些营地里。我比以往任何时候都强烈地意识到，当我问他是否觉得这里格格不入时，我其实是在问他是否宁愿自己已经死了。到苏联真正解体、没有什么能阻止他回去的时候，他觉得太晚了。
I already became very American. My life is here.
我已经变得很美国化了。我的生活在这里。
At your trial, you were talking about the attitude of the authorities to the people. And you said, "this is what I have fought against and what I shall continue to fight against for the rest of my life." Could you have imagined then this future that you've had?
在你的审判中，你谈到了当局对人民的态度。你说：“这就是我所抗争的，也是我余生将继续抗争的。”你当时能想象到你现在的这个未来吗？
About continue it the rest of my life, I still believe in those things. I still, when I can, contribute whatever little I can contribute to that. I do it. But it's a different life. And you change with age. When I left Russia, I was 33 and now I am almost 60. So the changes are there. So I'm a different person. I still feel a lot of connection, but I know that I am American.
关于余生继续抗争，我仍然相信这些事情。只要我能，我仍然为之贡献出我所能贡献的一点力量。我确实这么做了。但这是一种不同的生活。随着年龄增长，你会改变。我离开俄罗斯时是33岁，现在我快60岁了。所以改变就在那里。我是一个不同的人。我仍然感到有很多联系，但我知道我是美国人。
In 1993, Yeltsin decided to bomb the first Russian parliament. I was so disgusted with that. And I wrote a letter which was published in several Russian newspapers. And most of my friends disagreed with me. And my very close friends started polemics against me, which I didn't mind. But basically, part of the message was-- which I minded-- that I don't live there, I don't understand life there. And from America, I have no right to say it. That was the implication, that I'm a foreigner. And I suddenly realized that they probably are right. And that was a good cure from any thoughts about returning.
1993年，叶利钦决定轰炸俄罗斯议会。我对此感到非常反感。我写了一封信，发表在几家俄罗斯报纸上。我的大多数朋友都不同意我。我非常亲密的朋友开始针对我进行辩论，我不介意。但基本上，信息的一部分是——我介意的——我不住在那里，我不了解那里的生活。而从美国发声，我没权利说。这就是暗示，我是外国人。我突然意识到他们可能是对的。这对我关于回归的任何想法都是一剂良药。
We're standing in front of 54 Maplewood Avenue in Newton, Massachusetts.
我们正站在马萨诸塞州牛顿市枫木大道54号门前。
If anyone should have a reasonable perspective on dissidents in the suburbs, it would be my old friend Matvei, who is dissident royalty. The kindly old Sakharov in the framed photo atop our stereo wasn't my grandfather, but he was Matvei's. And for most of Matvei's childhood, he was exiled in Gorky. Matvei's family lived near us-- cross Rt. 9 on Parker, take a right and another right-- and we had Russian and chess lessons together as part of a parental rear-guard action against our creeping Americanization. His parents listened to Galich too.
如果说有谁对郊区的异见人士有合理的视角，那一定是我老朋友马特维，他可是“异见王室”。我们音响上那张装裱照片里慈祥的萨哈罗夫祖父不是我的祖父，但他是马特维的。在马特维童年的大部分时间里，他都在高尔基流亡。马特维一家住得离我们很近——穿过9号公路，在派克街右转再右转——我们一起上俄语和国际象棋课，那是我们父母为对抗我们日益增长的美国化而采取的后卫行动。他父母也听加利奇。
More importantly, his father was Sakharov's spokesman in the West. So they always had reporters and camera crews swarming the house.
更重要的是，他父亲是萨哈罗夫在西方的发言人。所以家里总是挤满了记者和摄像团队。
I think that a lot of the neighbors were very suspicious of us. And because my dad was so busy, he didn't have time to rake the lawn or mow the grass sometimes. And people would complain and say that our house was-- that we weren't being respectful to our Newton neighbors because we weren't cleaning up.
我想很多邻居对我们非常怀疑。因为我爸爸太忙了，有时没时间耙草地或修剪草坪。人们会抱怨，说我们的房子——说我们不尊重牛顿邻居，因为我们不搞好卫生。
But it lowers the property value if you don't mow your lawn.
但如果不修剪草坪会降低房产价值。
Right. Exactly. We were committing a Capitalist sin.
对，没错。我们犯了资本主义的罪。
I tell Matvei that as a child, I found it hard to have an American life at school and a Russian life at home. But maybe he felt different because his parents were on a mission from God.
我告诉马特维，作为一个孩子，我觉得很难在学校过美国生活，在家里过俄罗斯生活。但也许他感觉不同，因为他的父母是在执行上帝的任务。
I didn't see myself as different from the other immigrant kids just because my parents were involved in this. It just meant that they would go away for a month to Europe or something. And I would be like, well, where are my parents? And they'd be touring Europe and talking to Mitterrand and I don't know, all sorts of weird people out there.
我并不觉得我和其他移民孩子有什么不同，仅仅因为我的父母参与了这些。这只是意味着他们会去欧洲一个月左右。而我会觉得，嗯，我父母呢？他们会在欧洲巡回，和密特朗谈话，还有我不知道的，各种奇怪的人。
Did you ever get called a Commie?
你有没有被叫过“共产党”？
Yeah, I remember being called something like-- my teachers in junior high would say things like, where are you "Russian" to? Mr. Roberts. Or Matvei, you look so Red today.
有，我记得被叫过一些类似——初中的老师会说些诸如，“你‘俄’（rush，谐音）去哪儿？”之类的。罗伯茨先生。或者，“马特维，你今天看起来真红。”
Like most kids, Matvei didn't think his family was so special until Sakharov died in 1989, when Matvei was 16, and they went to Moscow for the funeral. 50,000 people came out to mourn his grandfather.
和大多数孩子一样，马特维直到1989年他16岁时萨哈罗夫去世、他们去莫斯科参加葬礼前，都没觉得他家有什么特别。5万人走上街头哀悼他的祖父。
And I think that was a turning point when I realized what I had missed, what I had not been old enough to really understand. It was just an incredible physical experience, in the sense that the space of Moscow was completely flooded by people following the coffin. And I remember just walking for miles behind, and sort of in a daze because I was thinking about all these things.
我想那是一个转折点，我意识到我错过了什么，我当时年纪太小没能真正理解什么。这是一种难以置信的身体体验，在那意义上，莫斯科的空间完全被跟随灵柩的人群淹没了。我记得在后面走了几英里，整个人处于一种恍惚状态，因为我一直在思考这些事情。
But it was not so much of a turning point that Matvei decided to devote his life to politics. I think Matvei learned something different from his parents' dissident lives than they probably ever intended. He has a dissident's relationship to the world but without the politics. He simply doesn't fit into society, and he doesn't seem distressed about it at all. He lives in a part of Brooklyn that's only barely connected to public transport. He does not have a job. He does various projects of his own invention. His latest is a biweekly 'zine on theatre theory.
但那并不是一个让马特维决定献身政治的转折点。我想马特维从他父母的异见生活中领悟到的东西，可能远非他们所愿。他与世界保持着一种异见式的关系，但没有政治色彩。他就是无法融入社会，而且他看起来一点也不为此感到苦恼。他住在布鲁克林一个几乎不通公共交通的地方。他没有工作。他进行着各种自己发明的项目。他最新的是一份关于戏剧理论的双周刊小册子。
Meanwhile, his family wants him to settle down to more traditional work and move closer to the trains. His grandmother, Yelena Bonner, who has been one of the Russian government's most acerbic critics, is also very critical of Matvei, especially since he dropped out of a doctoral program at Yale.
与此同时，他的家人希望他安定下来，找一份更传统的工作，搬到靠近火车的地方。他的祖母叶连娜·邦纳，曾是俄罗斯政府最尖锐的批评者之一，也对马特维非常不满，特别是在他从耶鲁大学的博士课程退学后。
She has often told me that she is going to die if I don't get a PhD.
她经常告诉我，如果我不拿到博士学位，她就会死。
What Matvei's family wants for him is the kind of life they had to forfeit. Political work took an enormous toll on his parents.
马特维家人想要他过那种他们不得不放弃的生活。政治工作对他父母造成了巨大的代价。
It was a completely marginal way of life. It meant just forgetting about a career and forgetting about a normal, decent human life. It just meant constantly running or constantly fighting something.
那是一种完全边缘化的生活方式。这意味着完全忘记职业，忘记正常、体面的生活。这只意味着不断奔波或不断与什么东西抗争。
For Matvei, there isn't very much glamour associated with dissidents. And so he doesn't find it so strange that they would live in the suburbs.
对马特维来说，异见人士身上没什么魅力。所以他并不觉得他们住在郊区有什么奇怪。
Well, maybe they got what they wanted. I don't feel like there's anything so shameful in that.
嗯，也许他们得到了他们想要的。我觉得这没什么可耻的。
Yeah, for me, just having the dissidents be something that were talked about in the house. And I probably have a more mythic view of them than you do. And maybe that's why I want to be so critical of them.
是啊，对我来说，仅仅因为在家里谈论“异见人士”这一话题。我可能对他们有比你更神话的看法。也许这就是为什么我想对他们这么挑剔。
Yeah, I don't know. I feel like it's hard for me to romanticize the dissidents because we never talked about "the dissidents" in my house. We talked about my grandpa and my grandma. And that was very different. And it was not really about their political choices but about survival.
是啊，我不知道。我觉得我很难浪漫化这些异见人士，因为我们在家里从不讨论“异见人士”。我们讨论的是我的爷爷和奶奶。那是很不同的。这与他们的政治选择无关，而是关于生存。
My name is Alexander Gessen and I am your father.
我叫亚历山大·格森，我是你父亲。
My father was not a dissident, but he brought all of us here from Russia and he raised me to admire them. He now lives in a big house near the ocean on Cape Cod. And he thinks it's ridiculous that I'm asking why the dissidents haven't returned.
我父亲不是异见人士，但他把我们全家从俄罗斯带到这里，并培养我崇敬他们。他现在住在科德角海边的一栋大房子里。他觉得我问异见人士为什么不回去这个问题很可笑。
They built their lives here. And do you want them to just extricate themselves and go back to nothing? It's very difficult.
他们在这里建立了他们的生活。你想要他们只是脱离现状回去一无所有吗？这很难。
If I feel this way, it's largely because you have instilled these ideas into me.
如果我有这种感觉，很大程度上是因为你把这些想法灌输给了我。
You feel what? Tell me what you feel. What are you talking about right now?
你有什么感觉？告诉我你的感觉。你现在在谈论什么？
Well, largely my idea of the moral life comes from listening to Galich, from listening to stories about political heroism and moral heroism. But meanwhile, we were in the suburbs. Does that makes sense to you as a contradiction?
嗯，很大程度上我的道德生活理念来自于听加利奇的歌，来自于听关于政治英雄主义和道德英雄主义的故事。但与此同时，我们却在郊区。这对你来说算是一个矛盾吗？
A contradiction between our lifestyle and our admirations? No, I don't think that everybody has to be a hero. Of course, if you are saying that you would prefer to have a father a hero, a dissident instead of just a suburban father, I could understand that.
我们的生活方式和我们的钦佩对象之间的矛盾？不，我不认为每个人都必须成为英雄。当然，如果你是说你宁愿有一个英雄般的父亲、一个异见人士父亲，而不是仅仅一个郊区的父亲，我能理解。
Well, I wasn't-- but the dissidents are also in the suburbs. So it would be the same situation, really.
嗯，我并不是——但异见人士也住在郊区。所以实际上是一样的情况。
You mean, these people are not heroic enough, that they stopped being heroes? This is what you are complaining about, yeah? Probably they did their part and they feel that they did enough. This is why they are staying here. They did their parts. They cannot do much now and they don't have to do anything now.
你是说，这些人不够英雄，他们不再做英雄了？这就是你在抱怨的，是吗？大概他们已经尽了他们的责任，他们觉得他们做得够多了。这就是为什么他们呆在这里。他们完成了他们的部分。他们现在做不了太多了，现在他们也不必做任何事了。
Of course my father's right. But somehow there's a part of me that feels the dissidents shouldn't be here. I think it's because, as a kid in the suburbs, I thought that history is what happened to other people, to people in Moscow and Paris and New York and Woodstock. They were out there doing these important things, and we were here, comfortable on Woodcliff Road, not doing much of anything at all.
我父亲当然是对的。但不知为何，我心中有一部分觉得异见人士不应该在这里。我想这是因为，作为一个郊区的孩子，我以为历史是发生在别人身上的事情，发生在莫斯科、巴黎、纽约和伍德斯托克的人身上。他们在外面做着那些重要的事情，而我们却在这里，舒适地待在木崖路上，什么也没做。
The suburbs are about sitting out history and about private lives. And the dissidents certainly have a right to all that. But when they were in Russia, they proved that it matters too what you do in public, that it is not enough to be moral behind the walls of your castle. They still believe that, of course, as I believe it, fiercely, from my comfortable, American home.
郊区是关于避开历史和关于私人生活。而异见人士当然有权拥有这一切。但当他们在俄罗斯时，他们证明了你在公共场合所做的事情也很重要，仅仅在你的城堡墙后做一个道德的人是不够的。他们当然依然相信这一点，正如我一样，在舒适的美国家中，强烈地相信这一点。
Keith Gessen in Massachusetts. He first wrote about dissidents in the suburbs for feedmagazine.com.
马萨诸塞州的基思·格森。他最初为 feedmagazine.com 撰写了关于郊区异见人士的文章。
Act Three, Shopping for a Better Future. What's left of an old neighborhood when a new one starts to form on top of it, when lots of money floods in but the old residents stick around? This American Life producer Julie Snyder has this story.
第三幕：《为更美好的明天购物》。当一个新的社区在旧社区上面开始形成，当大量资金涌入但旧居民仍留在原处时，旧社区还剩下什么？《美国生活》制片人朱莉·斯奈德带来了这个故事。
It says something that one of the most profound social experiments in Chicago is happening inside a supermarket. And while the executives of Dominick's Finer Foods wouldn't call it an experiment, there's really no other way to see it. For years, leaders from Jesse Jackson to Ronald Reagan have argued that if businesses would just locate in poorer areas, entire communities could change. This is a story of a corporation that tried to follow that model.
芝加哥最深远的社会实验之一发生在一家超市内部，这说明了一些问题。虽然 Dominick's Finer Foods 的高管不会称之为实验，但真的没有其他方式来看待它了。多年来，从杰西·杰克逊到罗纳德·里根，领导人们一直争论说，如果企业能在贫困地区设点，整个社区就能改变。这是一个公司试图遵循这种模式的故事。
See, this used to be, like, a predominantly black neighborhood. And up until maybe two years ago, it just like changed overnight. Overnight.
你看，这里曾经是一个以黑人为主的社区。直到也许两年前，它像一夜之间就变了。一夜之间。
Justin Thomas has lived in the Cabrini-Green housing projects on and off for the last 30 years, and works in the new store Dominick's built across the street. A thoughtful man who treats everyone like he's their older brother, he tells me that his job in the store cafe is to basically "do everything the females can't," which basically means a lot of heavy lifting and cleaning.
贾斯汀·托马斯在 Cabrini-Green 公屋断断续续住了30年，在 Dominick's 新店对面工作。他是一个体贴的人，对待每个人就像是他们的哥哥，他告诉我他在店里咖啡馆的工作基本上就是“做所有女性做不了的事”，这意味着大量的重体力活和清洁工作。
There was a lot of crazy stuff happening over here. A few years ago, you could barely rest for shooting and gangs and stuff. And they started tearing down some of the buildings in the projects. And when the neighborhood, the community could have been in a real crisis, up pops this store.
这儿发生过很多疯狂的事。几年前，因为枪击和帮派，你几乎无法安宁。他们开始拆除公屋里的一些楼房。当邻居和社区可能陷入真正危机时，这家店出现了。
Two years ago, the Chicago city government began a massive revitalization of the Cabrini-Green area. They gave economic incentives to Dominick's to move in. Old buildings came down. A new library went up. A park opened. And acres were cleared to build three-story townhomes where trashed-out cars and crack houses once stood. The whole neighborhood began to look different, people living in the projects next door to yuppies in the new condos and lofts. One afternoon, Justin and I go out to the parking lot in front of the supermarket.
两年前，芝加哥市政府开始对 Cabrini-Green 地区进行大规模振兴。他们给予 Dominick's 经济激励来入驻。旧建筑被拆除。新图书馆建起来了。公园开放了。曾经停放破烂汽车和存在吸毒窝点的土地被清理出来，建起了三层联排别墅。整个社区开始看起来不同了，住在公屋的人和住进新公寓阁楼的雅皮士成了邻居。一天下午，贾斯汀和我去超市前的停车场。
Over there to the right was a basketball court. Right there where the Blockbuster is. I think it may be extended from the Blockbuster maybe to right here.
在那边右侧有个篮球场。就在那个百视达那里。我想它可能从百视达一直延伸到这里。
Like, to maybe where this BMW is right here?
就像，延伸到这辆宝马这里？
Yeah. It was like a haven, really, for people that get high.
对。那里真的成了人们吸毒者的天堂。
Of the 6,000 people who live in the projects, 93% are unemployed. And when Dominick's cut their deal with the city, they agreed to hire 2/3 of their workforce from the neighborhood.
在住公屋的6000人中，93%失业。当 Dominick's 与市政府达成协议时，他们同意从社区雇佣2/3的员工。
It's one thing to set out to do something like this, and you get all of the warm and fuzzies and everything looks good. And then you get the store up and running, and then it falls apart.
一心想要做这件事是一回事，你得到了所有温暖和模糊的感觉，一切看起来都不错。然后商店开业了，接着事情就分崩离析了。
Dwayne Howard is the head of human resources at Dominick's. An African American man in his 40s, he first started coming to Cabrini-Green a decade ago. For years, he was here every week as part of the Cabrini-Green tutoring program and thought he knew a little bit about the neighborhood. But even he was surprised at how unprepared some people were for regular work. 35-year-old men were applying who'd never held any jobs ever.
德韦恩·霍华德是 Dominick's 的人力资源主管。一位40多岁的非裔美国人，他十年前第一次来到 Cabrini-Green。多年来，他每周都来这里参加 Cabrini-Green 补习项目，以为自己对这个社区了解一二。但即使是他也对一些人对正常工作毫无准备感到惊讶。申请的人里有35岁从未持有过任何工作的人。
There's no other way to put it other than you need to be sensitive to what has been a way of life for some of the employees that are working in the store, having been a product of their upbringing in the Cabrini-Green housing project.
没有别的方法可以说，你必须对商店里一些员工的生活方式保持敏感，因为他们是 Cabrini-Green 公屋成长起来的产品。
The city paid for a two-week course where applicants were taught not to wear jeans to their interviews, to bring their own pens to fill out applications, to not argue with customers, to come to work on time. In short, Dominick's ran into exactly the same problems that any government agency or charity slams up against when it tries to move people off welfare and into jobs.
市政府资助了一个为期两周的课程，教申请者面试时不要穿牛仔裤，带上自己的笔填写申请表，不要与顾客争吵，按时上班。简而言之，Dominick's 遇到了与任何政府机构或慈善机构在试图让人们脱离福利进入工作岗位时所面临的完全相同的问题。
The Cabrini store manager told me that even now, some employees won't come in for days. And when they do finally show up, they're shocked to find out they've been fired. A few months back, two step-sisters, one working the register and the other bagging groceries, had an argument brewing their entire shift, ending with punches being thrown right there at the checkout line.
Cabrini 的店经理告诉我，即使是现在，一些员工也会连续几天不来上班。当他们最终出现时，发现自己被解雇了，会感到很震惊。几个月前，两个继姐妹，一个做收银员，另一个装袋，在整个轮班期间就在酝酿争吵，最终在收银台前大打出手。
Most of the early hires didn't work out. One manager who'd been at 14 stores over 25 years said he'd never seen a turnover rate so high. Store execs won't say how many of the original staff of 250 are still with Dominick's, but they admit it may be as low as 1/4. And every employee they let go, they have to find and hire another from the neighborhood.
大多数早期雇员都没留下来。一位在25年里管理过14家分店的经理说他从未见过流失率这么高的。商店高管不会说最初250名员工中还有多少人留在 Dominick's，但他们承认比例可能低至1/4。而每解雇一名员工，他们就必须从社区找并雇佣另一名。
None of this gives you a sense of the atmosphere in the store, which in a way is the most remarkable thing about the entire experiment. When I first walked into the Dominick's about six months ago, a store employee, a small woman in her 70s, greeted me at the door, handed me a shopping basket, and told me to let her know if there was anything she could help me find.
这一切都不能让你感受到店里的氛围，而这在某种程度上是整个实验最引人注目的地方。大约六个月前，当我第一次走进这家 Dominick's 时，一位70多岁的小个子店员在门口迎接我，递给我一个购物篮，并告诉我如果有什么要找的可以告诉她。
In the aisles, customers were chatting with each other. Teens from Cabrini hang out by the pizza slice counter. Elderly men drink coffee and read the paper in the store cafe. At the checkout line, the cashier was telling a joke, a slightly racy one even, to the customer in front of me. It didn't seem like they knew each other, but they were both laughing. She was maybe 20, African-American. He was a balding white guy.
在通道里，顾客们互相聊天。来自 Cabrini 的青少年在披萨柜台闲逛。老年男子在店里咖啡馆喝咖啡看报纸。在收银台，收银员在给我前面的顾客讲笑话，还是个有点俏皮的笑话。他们看起来好像并不认识，但他们都在笑。她可能20岁，非裔美国人。他是个秃顶白人。
I thought maybe this was some sort of special day at Dominick's, like maybe the employees were being evaluated or it was the store's anniversary. But almost every time I've gone back, the same types of things happen. If you ask an employee where something is, they don't just point in a general direction and leave. They actually drop what they're doing and take you over to the product. There's a man who works in the liquor department who has stopped my husband in the store, taken his bottle of wine out of the cart, and replaced it with a cheaper and better version.
我本以为这可能是 Dominick's 的什么特殊日子，比如员工被评估或者是商店周年庆。但几乎每次我回去，同样的事情都会发生。如果你问店员某样东西在哪里，他们不会只是指个大概方向然后离开，他们真的会放下手头的事，带你走到商品前。酒水部门有一位男士曾在大厅拦住我丈夫，从购物车里拿出他选的葡萄酒，换成了一个更便宜、更好的版本。
People seem genuinely happy to have these jobs and to have the first decent store they've ever had in this neighborhood. It's also one of the most comfortably integrated environments in Chicago. The diversity of the stock is almost a laughably obvious metaphor for the diversity of the customers. Collard greens sit next to arugula. Smoked ham hocks and turkey tails literally lay right next to gourmet smoked sausage with sun-dried tomato, basil, and pine nuts.
人们似乎真心为拥有这些工作以及在这个社区拥有他们有史以来第一家像样的商店而感到高兴。这也是芝加哥融合最舒适的环境之一。商品的多元化几乎是对顾客多元化一个显而易见的隐喻。羽衣甘蓝旁边放着芝麻菜。烟熏火腿肘子和火鸡尾巴真的就放在美味的晒干番茄、罗勒和松子烟熏香肠旁边。
I like the store. It's OK. I don't think that they really built that store for us.
我喜欢这家店。还可以。我不认为他们真的是为我们建的。
Who do you think they built it for?
你认为他们是为谁建的？
Oh, for the people moving in. The middle class people with more money than we have.
哦，为搬进来的人。比我们更有钱的中产阶级。
Dan Underwood has lived in the area all of his life, before the housing projects were even built. He headed the grammar school's champion drill team and runs a community gardening project called Cabrini Greens where kids grow vegetables and sell them at a profit.
丹·安德伍德一生都住在这个地区，在公屋建成之前就住了。他领导了小学冠军操练队，并经营着一个叫 Cabrini Greens 的社区园艺项目，孩子们在这里种植蔬菜并盈利出售。
When I ask him what remains of the old neighborhood now that it has a new shopping center, he tells me, pretty much everything-- gangs, drugs, and poor people. Standing in between three of the high-rises, it's clear the benefits of redevelopment don't extend much further than the plot of land Dominick's sits on.
当我问他，既然有了新的购物中心，老社区还剩下什么时，他告诉我，几乎剩下了一切——帮派、毒品和穷人。站在三栋高层建筑之间，很明显重建的益处并没有延伸到 Dominick's 所在的土地之外太远。
See now, do you see the police car sitting out front right here?
看看现在，你看到那辆停在前门处的警车了吗？
He points at a squad car and one woman yelling down from the fifth floor to a woman in the parking lot who ignores her and strides away.
他指着一辆警车，还有一位妇女从五楼对着停车场里的另一位妇女大喊大叫，后者没理她径直走开了。
Oh, those people. They're arguing about drugs. They're arguing about drugs. But the guys will be standing right down there selling drugs now. When the police come, they're all going out of there.
哦，那些人。他们在为毒品争吵。他们是在为毒品争吵。但那些家伙现在就会站就在下面卖毒品。警察来了，他们就全都散了。
How often do the police come by?
警察多久来一次？
Oh, God. A lot. They're here all the time. They never leave. They never leave.
哦，上帝。经常。他们一直都在这儿。他们从不离开。他们从不离开。
Dan says what everyone at Cabrini says, that it's just a matter of time before the city tears down the high-rises and sends them all packing. People said this to me months ago, and it wasn't clear if it was paranoia. And then recently, they were proven right in every detail.
丹说出了所有 Cabrini 人的心声，说城市拆除高层建筑并把他们全部赶走只是时间问题。几个月前人们就这么对我说过，当时还不清楚这是否是妄想。而最近，他们在每一个细节上都被证明是对的。
The housing authority has announced a plan to demolish the Cabrini high-rises and build a mixed-income community in its place. It's still not entirely clear how it will shake out, but the most likely scenario is this-- some people will be allowed to stay in the neighborhood in new and improved public housing, and the rest-- probably most people-- will be moved to poor neighborhoods, God knows where, or abandoned.
住房管理局宣布了一项计划，拆除 Cabrini 的高层建筑并在原址建立一个混合收入社区。虽然还不清楚结果会如何，但最可能的情况是——有些人会被允许留在社区住进新的、改善后的公屋，而其余的人——可能大多数人——会被搬到贫困社区，天知道在哪里，或者是被遗弃。
Things change so much. When I was a little boy, eight, nine years old, those projects were not there. The rural houses, do you know where they are? On the other side of Oak Street, that was Italian. The Italians lived there. And black kids couldn't walk over there. You got in a fight. Italian gangs were there. And you walked over there, you got in a fight.
事情变了很多。我八、九岁的时候，那些公屋还没建起来。那些农村住宅，你知道它们在哪里吗？在橡树街的另一边，那是意大利区。意大利人住在那里。黑人孩子走不过去。你会被打的。意大利帮派就在那儿。你走过去，就会卷入打斗。
The only time that you were allowed to come over there was on Babaluci Day, which was when they had the carnivals and stuff. You could go there. They'd let you come during Babaluci Day. And you could come to ride on the Ferris Wheel and all that kind of stuff. And the Cardinal would come and he had his float. And it was peaceful then, that day. After that, the next day, you couldn't go over there. You couldn't go over there.
唯一被允许过去的时间是“巴巴露西节”，那时候他们会有嘉年华什么的。你可以去那儿。他们会让你在“巴巴露西节”期间过去。你可以去坐摩天轮之类的东西。枢机主教也会来，他有他的花车。那时候是和平的。在那之后，第二天，你就不能过去了。你不能过去。
So in a way, right now, this time period is sort of like Babaluci Day. You can come in.
所以某种程度上，现在这段时期有点像“巴巴露西节”。你可以进来。
You can come in. You can come in and you can come to the Dominick's. But this is not for you. You have to go.
你可以进来。你可以进来并来到 Dominick's。但这不属于你。你必须离开。
Everyone assumes the few people who will be allowed to stay in the area and live in the nice, new public housing will be the best bets, people who are off public aid, people with jobs. With this in mind, Justin, who's only worked in the store for four months, has made it his own personal project to informally recruit people for jobs at Dominick's. He talks it up at his Baptist Church. He encourages his kid's friends. When people find out he works at Dominick's, he helps to set them up with interviews.
每个人都认为，少数被允许留在该地区并住进漂亮新公屋的人将是最好的赌注，即脱离公共援助的人，有工作的人。考虑到这一点，只在店里工作了四个月的贾斯汀，已经把非正式地为 Dominick's 招聘人员变成了他自己的个人项目。他在他的浸信会教堂谈论这件事。他鼓励他孩子的伙伴们。当人们发现他在 Dominick's 工作时，他会帮助他们安排面试。
I mean, in a few years from now, if you're not in the workplace, where are you going to be? The way the neighborhood is changing, where are you going to be? You definitely can't live over here and sell drugs. That's going to be a thing of the past. So what do you do? So it's kind of like shaping up for those people that will and for those that won't. I don't know. I mean, God help them. I don't know where they'll be years from now.
我的意思是，几年后，如果你不在职场，你会去哪儿？社区变化的方式，你会去哪儿？你绝对不能住在这里并卖毒品。那将成为过去的事情。所以你要做什么？所以这对那些愿意做的人和那些不愿意做的人来说，有点像是一种塑造。我不知道。我的意思是，上帝帮助他们。我不知道几年后他们会在哪儿。
At this point, the results of this social experiment are as follows-- a few hundred people have gotten and held on to jobs, some in ways that have changed their lives. And 6,000 Cabrini residents will mostly feel the experiment's effects on the day they're told to move out.
目前，这个社会实验的结果如下——几百人得到了并保住了工作，有些人以改变生活的方式做到了。而6000名 Cabrini 居民在被告知要搬走的那一天，将主要感受到这个实验的影响。
Julie Snyder. To visit the most interesting supermarket in America, it's Division and Sedgwick here in Chicago.
朱莉·斯奈德。要参观美国最有趣的超市，就在芝加哥的 Division 和 Sedgwick。
Our program produced today by Julie and myself with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Blue Chevigny.
我们今天的节目由朱莉和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿和布鲁·切维尼协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who kills every tender moment between us by saying--
WBEZ 的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他总是通过说这句话来扼杀我们之间每一个温柔的时刻——
Mm-yesss?
嗯——是的？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。